that's an important parameter is how do
you feel during the day
almost everybody experiences some sort
of dip in energy in the late afternoon
or what would correlate to their
temperature peak
and that's a good time of day to get
either a 90
90 minute or less nap or if you're not a
napper
or you can't nap feet elevated
has been shown to be good for clear out
of some of this
the glymphatic system is this kind of
like sewer system of the brain that you
can clear stuff out
so legs elevated or one thing that i've
um i'm a big proponent of and that my
lab has been studying is what i i now
call
nsdr non-sleep deep breast and this is
just
lying down there are some scripts that
we're going to put out there soon as
a free resource there's some hypnosis
scripts that my colleague david spiegel
has put out there as a free resource
but non-sleep deep rest is allowing your
system to drop into states of
of real calm that allow you to get
better at falling asleep later
and they can be very restorative for
cognitive and motor function
there's at least one study out of
denmark that shows that
the basal ganglia which is an area of
the brain that's involved in motor
planning and action
one of these 20-minute non-sleep deep
breast protocols
resets levels of neuromodulators like
dopamine in the basal ganglia to
the same levels that they were right
after a long night's sleep
so i also respectfully uh
or semi-respectfully disagree with the
idea that you can't recover lost sleep
what does that mean i mean that there's
no irs for sleep
so what does it mean to be in debt for
sleep
if you're falling asleep during the day
and you're sleepy like you're falling
asleep that's
a good sign of insomnia means you're not
sleeping enough at night
if you're fatigued during the day but
you're not falling asleep so you're just
exhausted but you're not finding
yourself falling asleep in meetings and
in conversation
then chances are you're fatiguing your
system through something else
like a long run in the middle of the
night in
boston or whatever it is that you're up
to lately at uh 3 a.m
yes there is a magic to the nap and
maybe you could speak to the because you
mentioned these protocols
that don't necessarily so they're
non-sleep
but to me the nap
one or two a day can
almost irrespective of how much sleep i
get the night before
uh have a fundamental change in my mood
and my
performance for the better for the
better for the better yeah likewise
so i do tend to kind of experiment with
durations
it's it's consistently surprising to me
how like a nap of like 10 minutes i
don't know maybe you can speak to the
perfect duration of a nap
but i find that it's like magic
that a short nap does as much good
and often better than a longer one for
me for me subjective what would be a
longer one
longer than 90 minutes no no like 90
minutes or but longer than 90
like two hours yeah that's dropping you
starting to drop you into rem sleep and
even if it's a tiny amount of rem sleep
people can come out of those naps kind
of disoriented
i mean remember in sleep space and time
are are totally uncoupled and so
they that's an odd state to re-enter the
world in if you're not going to stay
there for a while like for a good
night's sleep
i think a 20-minute nap is pretty
fantastic
would you say that's the op if you were
to recommend to the general and
it's very weird to recommend anything to
the general populace because
obviously it's very person specific but
what's a good one will you say to
friends is 20 minutes
30 minutes 20 or 30 minutes because
you're going unless you're sleep
deprived
you're going to stay out of rem sleep
rapid eye movement sleep if you're sleep
deprived you'll drop right into it if
you've ever traveled and you're really
jet lagged you go to the hotel you lay
down for one second all of a sudden
you're just like
you're you're in a psychedelic dream um
which can be pretty great too but i
think that
uh 20 30 minutes and if you can't sleep
some people have
trouble napping then learning to relax
the body as much as possible like trying
to remove
all expression from your face completely
letting your body kind of float
if people have a hard time relaxing when
they're awake
there's some terrific clinically and
research tested hypnosis protocols
that we could provide links to that are
cost free and that teach you how to just
completely
release the alertness button and you
just start drifting now the problem is
if you don't have an alarm or something
to go off you
the other day i did one and i'm almost
embarrassed to say this but there's a
component of it where you actually are
supposed to let your hand float up
because it's a hypnosis script so they
it's my colleague david spiegel in the
script he says
um let your hand float up i woke up an
hour later my hand was still floating
wow yeah and i was
and i was completely relaxed so
hypnosis is hypnosis is just a matter of
going deep relaxation narrowing of
context
and it's all self-imposed a lot of
people think that hypnosis is like the
stage thing with the pendant and the
chicken
you know people [ __ ] like chickens
but real hypnosis
is self-hypnosis you're learning to it
involves
some shifts in the way that you the
hypnotic induction involves looking up
closing your eyes slowly deep breath and
then imagine yourself floating
and people vary on a scale of about one
to four for being the
most easily hypnotized there are a few
people who it's very hard for them to
allow themselves to to go into these
states but for most people
they just they're gone and it's nice if
if you can have access to those states
because when you come out of it
you feel amazing you feel like you slept
the whole night at least
most people report that
you